men don't trust women women don't trust
men is there an end in sight is it going
to happen in our in our lifetime or are
American men just gonna be like you know
what I'm throwing my hands up I'm gonna
I'm gonna [__] my sex doll or I'm gonna
go to Southeast Asia and I'm leaving
women alone I think when you start to
see the benefits rolling I think at some
point the government's gonna run out of
money yeah and I think once we start to
see I think women are very opportunistic
yes and I think as students you start to
see like the benefits rolling back
that's when you'll see women running to
their friend zone there you go please
marry me please